jean slim atik et la justice sociale
nous demandons à nos élus de mettre en
place le plus rapidement possible la
gratuité des transports en commun je
dois rébellion et extinction de voix à
force de clamer ses convictions
symboliquement enchaînés aux
distributeurs de tickets les militants
du mouvement ont lancé leur besac
attaque pour interpeller les élus et
sensibiliser les usagers fait appel aux
gens leur donne les tickets gratuits et
on les invite à ne pas valider leur
carte aujourd'hui pour justement
revendiqué cette gratuité des transports
en commun l'urgence et c'est le climat
c'est la pollution donc pour encourager
les personnes à abandonner des moyens de
transport polluants comme les voitures
je pense qu'il faut les encourager à des
moyens de transport en commun et pour ça
au lieu d'augmenter le prix des tarifs
comme ça a été fait cet été
baa l'idée c'est plutôt de rendre les
transports gratuits comme ça avait été
promis à l'échelle nationale comme c'est
déjà le cas dans 30 villes en france
outre les arrêts de la plage chamard
l'opération a été menée à la gare viotte
sur l'air de l'urgence climatique et de
la justice sociale la crise écologique
c'est quelque chose qui est vaste qui
est complètement lié à des tas dangereux
extrêmement différents donc aujourd'hui
on s'attaque au sujet des transports
mais dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent on va faire d'autres actions
sur plein d'autres sujets le mouvement a
été levée en milieu de matinée en
prenant soin de nettoyer les lieux